zoe de chanel has been largely absent
from our screens over the past couple of
years
but happily it's for several solid
reasons
here's why you haven't seen zoe de
chanel in tv or movies as much lately
from 2011 to 2018 zoe de chanel starred
as jessica day
a sweet quirky teacher who moves in with
three strangers in los angeles
after a terrible breakup on the hit
comedy new girl
who's jess though the role netted her
emmy and golden globe nominations
it may have also pigeonholed her as a
performer there's no question that
jess and deschanel share a lot of traits
from their musical talents to their love
of vintage clothing and early seasons of
new girl
really leaned on those similarities the
show sharpened a bit
in later seasons and even poked fun at
jess's highly manicured quirkiness
unfortunately if you didn't invest in
new girl long term
you missed all that evolution which
potentially made her harder to cast in
roles that differed too drastically from
jess
between her leading role on new girl and
her starring turn
alongside joseph gordon levitt in 500
days of summer the fact is that many of
deschanel's most high-profile characters
fit the definition of the manic pixie
dream girl
a term coined by critic nathan rabin
after he saw cameron crowe's 2005 film
elizabethtown it became a catch-all
phrase for quirky female characters
and unfortunately deschanel fit the
stereotype to a t
at least superficially for example 500
days of summer's leading lady
summer could best be described as a
manic pixie dream girl
by detractors who would prefer to ignore
the depths of the character
as well as the strength of deschanel's
performance diminishing summer to a girl
who loves vintage clothes
is tweely eccentric and who encourages
the film's male protagonist to make
big choices in his life rabin ultimately
apologized for even creating the concept
of a manic pixie dream girl years later
but the popularity of the trope
and its backlash may have affected
deschanel's opportunities in hollywood
plenty of actors have moved into
producing while still appearing in front
of the camera
even megawatt stars like brad pitt who
actually won his first academy award for
producing 12 years a slave
several years before he won a
competitive oscar for acting
zoe deschanel is no different in fact
she moved behind the camera on new girl
during its run
in 2011 she became a producer and from
2014
until the show ended in 2018 also served
as an executive producer
deschanel also ventured into producing
some other projects throughout her run
on new girl
even if she isn't appearing on screen in
other words
there's always a chance deschanel could
produce again if the right project
catches her eye aside from her acting
career
one of zoe deschanel's long time passion
projects
has been promoting vegan and vegetarian
lifestyles
while helping consumers understand where
their food actually comes from
for multiple seasons deschanel has
hosted the web series your foods roots
where she talks to farmers nutritionists
food historians
and other experts about how the food you
choose affects you
as well as the people around you larger
communities and
the earth as a whole in fact working on
the show
encouraged deschanel to become a
vegetarian to adopt more ethical food
practices
as she once explained to people magazine
she learned
so much about where her food was really
coming from that she began paying more
attention
the main thing is it's just so hard to
know where meat is coming from
it's so difficult to know if it was
sustainably raised or humanely raised
i really felt like i couldn't be sure
where it was coming from most of the
time
so i stopped eating meat near the height
of her career momentum in 2011
zoe deschanel found time to create a
place for women of all ages
online alongside co-founders molly
mcaleer
and sophia rossi deschanel founded hello
giggles
just as she landed her starring role on
new girl according to hello giggles
itself
the site is meant to serve as a quote
positive online community for female
identifying readers
and covers everything from beauty to
relationship to finance
to do this the site combines personal
essays with news
lists and columns in 2015
deschanel mclear and rossi sold hello
giggles to time
inc but still continued overseeing the
website as it gained an even wider
audience as deschanel told the los
angeles times in a statement
the purchase meant the trio and their
staff would be able to reach an even
wider audience through the resources
offered by time hello giggles is still
around to do that
today in 2015 zoe deschanel took on one
of the most important roles
of her life becoming a mother with the
birth of her first child
daughter elsie wolf in 2017 with
then-husband jacob pachenek she had a
son
charlie wolf before the couple parted
ways in 2019.
in 2018 deschanel told instyle that she
was in no rush to return to acting
preferring to focus on her children i'm
just looking for something that would be
exciting
and fulfilling for me i have two kids
and they're very important to me
i'm really focused on them so i want to
make sure that whatever i do next
is really good it has to be really good
for me to leave them
and go to work by deschanel's own
admission
she's also a very hands-on parent as she
also told in style
i mean i'm driving my kids to every
class every day
i'm there with them all the time it's
actually rare that i'm not with them
i try to be there as much as humanly
possible
ever since new girl ended in 2018
audiences haven't seen zoe deschanel on
screen
in an acting role but if you listen
closely to some recent
and huge children's movies you'll be
able to hear her distinctive voice
live action acting might be on hold but
voice acting is still a part of
deschanel's working life
in 2016 deschanel began appearing in the
enormously successful trolls franchise
voicing bridget a member of the
antagonistic bergen race
however bridget is a particularly sweet
bergen
harboring a secret crush on the prince
of the bergens
grissel jr and working as a scullery
maid
in the palace you love crystal too
you better back off girlfriend after the
first film
deschanel returned not only for the
much-anticipated 2020 sequel trolls
world tour
which marked her first acting gig since
2017
but she also appeared in nbc's trolls
holiday special
reprising her role as bridget in both
projects
whether it's to cater to her children or
just because voice work is a fun gig for
major actors to play with
deschanel is clearly doing well with her
work in the trolls movies
even throughout the highest highs of her
film and television career
zoe deschanel always kept her true
passion project
the band she and him alive alongside
partner
m ward the duo has released several
albums
and with deschanel on piano vocals and
ukulele and ward on guitar
the two strike a decidedly folksy sound
they've been quite successful
releasing 2008's volume 1 2010's volume
2 2013's volume 3 and a very she and tim
christmas
2014's classics and 2016's christmas
party
between albums ward and deschanel also
play live
as recently as 2019 the two were still
doing holiday tours
visiting several cities during the
season to spread musical cheer
in fact during their 2019 christmas
party tour
chanelle was spotted bringing her famous
boyfriend property brother jonathan
scott
on stage during a show at the met in
philadelphia
after a meeting during a taping of
carpool karaoke
in 2019 zoe deschanel and hgtv star
and property brother jonathan scott
started dating
and over time the two slowly made their
relationship
public throughout several cute instagram
posts and other milestones
deschanel and scott have opened up about
their relationship
and in december of 2020 deschanel put in
an appearance alongside scott
on his home network deschanel appeared
in an episode of the
hgtv series celebrity iou
which sees celebrities do special
construction and renovations favors for
friends
and loved ones via the hosting and
producing powers of the property
brothers
in this sweet installment deschanel
helps out a longtime friend
sarah who has been a part of her life
since kindergarten
by expanding her home into an open space
concept
beyond deschanel's amazing gesture it's
even cuter knowing that she's appearing
alongside scott
her real-life partner and supporting his
television ventures
zoe deschanel's blunt bangs adorkable
personality
and ukulele-fueled indie band have made
her an easily spoofable celebrity
over the years now that she's out of the
spotlight
deschanel is poking fun at herself and
even appeared in a music video alongside
katy perry to reference
a long-running joke there's no denying
that deschanel
and perry look eerily similar to the
point where perry
even admitted that she occasionally
pretended to be
deschanel to gain access to exclusive
events and clubs
finally in december of 2020 the duo made
light of their similarity when deschanel
starred in the music video for perry's
song
not the end of the world one of the
singles from her smile
album in the video deschanel plays an
unsuspecting human who finds herself
held captive by
aliens who really really like katy perry
and even try to get deschanel's
character to perform as the pop star
it's a bit that
perfectly capitalizes on the constant
claims that the two stars
are lookalikes check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one